Peter Brown we had you on here last week
to talk about the oculus rift hey thanks
so much coming in hey you play a lot of
VR games and then the wife came along
and you have to play more of that so
you've played the vibe now it seems like
for a good week and change well we only
got it on Wednesday what we have like a
we haven't got a pre-production yeah I
didn't put too much time in with that
because I figured all the way for the
final one they're identical but I've
used it a lot in previous events so yes
I am experienced an hour review went off
on gamespot com today I believe this
Martin excellent cool so let's dive into
this a little bit first of all first
things first direct comparison between
the two of them hard to make considering
you know controllers are involved in one
and the price pipe points all that sort
of stuff but what are you feeling at the
moment is somebody who if you just had
access to both of them which one would
you go for if I had access to both of
them right now not someone who's trying
to come up with a feature or review more
like a cold comparison right like just a
real human decision I would choose rift
really yeah Wisie far easier to set up
far easier and more comfortable to
actually use for extended periods of
time and I felt like I was able to jump
into the store and identify games that
were interesting to me and unlike with
vibe I found fully realized games right
a lot of the stuff in vibe was you know
currently is like tech demo type stuff
right there's a game it's like Oh selfie
tennis and you're like what's his tennis
game literally play tennis with yourself
you hit the ball the other side of the
court the camera jumps over you hit it
back there's no menu do you get the same
goal no it's fine um and yeah an oculus
is it's a far more elegant and refined
product like it's it's not it doesn't
have the same number of components or
capabilities of vibe but that's just
right now right oculus is releasing
their touch controllers later this year
they can do room scale VR you just need
a second sensor right and when that
happens I think people are going to
realize that that is the product that is
the more user-friendly by far mmm just
maybe not at the box has as much options
let's not talk about the setup stuff
first of all because have you set it up
in multiple rooms right the five I had
you know you owe me do comparison or
just talk about 50 50 K so setting up
five when you have enough space the
maximum playroom area is 15 by 15 feet
but you can do it in less than that but
let's say you have 15 by 15 feet it's
very easy granted you have the ability
to mount the two base stations the
things that project infrared light that
is and picked up by the headset in the
controllers do they have to be floating
in the air somewhere I do have like
drill demands they have smaller it's
recommended that they're at least six
and a half feet above the ground ago I
was able to set them up closer to like
five feet at home because I had to so
you have to place those you have to like
trace your your room using one of the
controllers and it determines like okay
you've got a big enough space or all you
need to do it again doing it at home I
could have sworn the space i had was
bigger than the minimum recommendation
which was five by six and a half feet
right but so you trace the room and then
it takes his virtual map and it puts it
in what you traced and it says okay it
fits her a dozen he was overlapping by a
hair and it was like sorry you don't
have sufficient space to do this start
over all right I had to do it like five
six times and basically lie and just
move the controller a little bit like
over the edge of my couch it was like
yeah rock on man you did it is this
something that you have to then repeat
every time so you got parents coming
over you got to take down the whole
thing mmm do I have to like do I'd like
a preset mode or anything like that if
you move the base stations you will have
to do it again okay um if you for some
reason like the software gets
disoriented you have to do it all again
cuz like there was one time where the
floor had suddenly jumped no matter what
I was into like I levels I was like
constantly looking like over the ground
right because you put the controllers on
the floor and the base stations detect
where the floor is so you have to kind
of go through some of that if it gets
messed up the intention for these things
that they will be set up permanently
valve so confidently said you know we
find that people make room for VR
alright which is like it's like such a
subjective thing though like who knows
right who has the room to make room for
VR let's talk about the actual headsets
themselves and I guess this is a
comparison question the oculus feels a
lot is it lighter or is it is it does it
fit snugger than the vibe what's going
on so
lighter the mix of materials is far
better especially when it comes to the
straps they are if they are sturdy in
just the right place so when you go to
put it on its it's stiff enough that you
don't actually have to like manhandle it
too much you just hold on to it to just
kind of control it but it slips on like
I like a stiff catcher's mask yeah vibe
has four cables coming out of the top
compared to oculus is one which kind of
comes out of the side and it's straps
are really floppy so when you go to put
it on that the cable is kind of like
pressure it down so you have to do this
little dance to kind of put it on which
in reality on its own terms isn't that
bad but after using riff for a week
where I got I could just slip it on like
I said it was a nuisance it definitely
like a news did to get loose is you were
using it or anything no no it wasn't
there not loose in that regard they're
just floppy right there's some rigidity
to riff straps um but what did bother me
too is that and this is subjective
because of my head I guess because no
one else has told me this but the straps
on the side are really wide okay so
whenever I put it on it's either digging
into my ears or overlapping them right I
could not get the headset to sit
comfortably without that happening also
it doesn't come with its own headset
right you mean headphones headphones
yeah right no it's got like a little
plug that's dangling and it comes with
headphones that you can plug into that
but again it's if still feels like a
prototype mmm you know like rift has
these built in there easily adjustable
they're comfortable they sound really
good honestly for just what you know
packed in over-ear headphone your
headphones and sounds really well so
what about the quality of life sort of
stuff like the UI you use trying to
surface games that they work well
because the vibe has access to like the
whole steam yeah you interface and
whatnot so is it difficult to find games
that are working for iPod I kind of had
assumed in my head that most of the
games that were coming out on reft are
also coming out on vibe but is that is
that not the case okay so with vive um
you work through steam VR which is sort
of a like runs on the side of steam and
detects a big screen stuff almost done
using yeah it's similar to that but at
the bottom of the screen when you're in
the menu you have the option to flip
from steam BR steam or your desktop okay
and I really really really appreciated
all of that because you know you're
looking at VR games and like that's all
well and good but like at the same time
like if you actually wanted you know if
you're in steam in some catches your eye
you think about something you can go
look it up um if you get a notification
on your desktop or you know whatever you
can actually go to your desktop and you
use the controller as sort of like a
laser pointer where I pointed things and
you click with the trigger have any type
huh how can you type it's got the
controller so it opens up to the touch
pad thing so you can use those navigate
like a split keyboard cool it works the
experience of going to pc works so well
and i didn't know how much i would
appreciate it until i started using it
there was one error i noticed we're in
steam have a video section and so like
you know things like kung fury were like
a documentary on a gamer on there and I
went to go play it as though it would
pop up in like a theater mode yeah steam
said it was doing that but then I
started hearing it and I put off the
headset was playing on the monitor right
so there's still some kinks to be worked
out but yeah like you know for rift it's
a much more simple experience it is just
the oculus home UI and you can import
videos and play them in like a theater
but that's the extent of what you can do
outside of oculus home with innocuous
home hmm so do you think there's more
room for improvement than in terms of
like because the 5 has access to all
this holds theme interface thing does
that seem like it works better with just
your wider pc as a tool set it does
provided that you are someone who is
very familiar with steam and you know
what it's like to be a pc gamer like
it's it's not the sort of thing that i
could hand to someone who doesn't play
games and say here figure this out like
they're gonna probably end up going to
menu somewhere and not realize what they
did to get there or how to get out riff
on the other hand is super intuitive at
technically in terms of you know
resolution and all that sort of their
identical yeah yeah didn't it feel any
different in terms of I space or like
when you bring on so the the way that
the objects are shaped in vibe is a
little bit different than rift rift is a
vase muth optical lens vive seems to
have these like steps you notice these
hard circles that go around right and
I'm not exactly sure why that is I'm
sure there's some research to support
that it helps but i will say image
is on the edge of the optics tended to
blur a little bit in a rift and this
segmentation of the knock the optic I
can't speak the office in vibe kind of
negated that a little bit adjusting the
distance between lenses you have sort of
a manual slider in an rift and you can't
you don't always know like if you give
it to somebody else you don't know where
your place was vive has a dial that when
you turn it it actually shows you a
distance like in a UI alright said so if
it ever gets changed you know ok my
distance is this just go right back to
them which is pretty awesome that is
useful you have the rift I was adjusting
that I was like I guess I'll find
somewhere that looks ok but to know like
I let me see one MC to MC yeah you see
one it's weird it's like they're sort of
holistic they are doing a lot of the
same well but there's just like little
parts and I guess you know it doesn't
matter to you a lot to sort of the build
of the unit because it does when it
comes to it affecting comfort right like
there is a an angle to the strap of rift
that goes up and then around right yeah
because they clearly ran into somebody
like me who can't have a strap coming
straight out because it digs into your
ear there's even a little like give so
you can tilt rift forward whereas vive
to do that you have to essentially
distend the strap with rift is just like
a quick little tilt and it's it goes
great like it just feels like a much
more thoughtfully designed headset what
would you say would you still like how
much of a because we're comparing
something like we're comparing them by
and by narrowly right it's like one or
the other like would you still recommend
a vibe to somebody if like oculus wasn't
around it couldnt get a pre-order for it
like it's still a pretty substantially
well created VR headset yeah yeah I mean
it's it's got the unfortunate thing that
it has to go up against a product that
came out last week yeah I mean these are
the two like you know Sonia side because
they're in a different market I think
the two high in VR headsets come on one
week you kind of have to talk about them
in that and that light but yes it is
good it works really well like the 360
motion tracking stuff is great it just
needs more software right now to support
it and i think the headset needs a
little more attention when it comes to
design last point on this you've been
playing with virtual reality for
time but you've been playing it quite
extensively over the past fortnight how
do you feel about the sort of long-term
effectiveness of your are you excited to
go home and then put the headset on you
excited to play more games like that
have you felt like you needed brakes
from vo and you you just want to sit
down and play a goddamn 2d video game
again like what is what is your feeling
from somebody who is very excited about
virtual reality right before at this
experience I think rift presents a
really good argument that VR is here
because you've got developers making
games that have had a lot of thought put
into them and are you know fully fledged
games even if some of them have just
simple activities the stuff that
supports them is robust enough to keep
you motivated to keep coming back there
are some experiences like that on vibe
for the most part it feels like it's
stuck in at like CES 2012 right like
this is VR you can do this thing and
it's kind of like a tennis racket and
this is kind of like a tennis ball you
know that that I'm not as convinced by
five especially because it's so
expensive and it's ridiculous to set up
like we didn't get into the nitty-gritty
of the setup but it's it's a pain in the
butt for me because it's so simple to
use because I know exactly what I'm
getting into when I look at the games on
the store rift is the best argument for
VR hitting the ground running at this
point cool yeah appreciate a Peter Brown
okay with VR headsets coming out next
week God we just got a pitch from
somebody for an android-based VR headset
great but it's not one that uses a
mobile phone who anybody uses mobile
phone tech inside of it so yeah get out
of here can you call people on it and
can you like just pick up the head
sentence to go up your face and go like
yo ma i'm in vr [ __ ] off you just slip
it you slip your mother like do you know
expensive long-distance calls me yeah do
they even have virtual reality in
Ireland jet Oh Stace join me what a babe
she doesn't watch the show it's fine hey
mom sorry yeah thanks so much Peter
you